en el último vídeo introduje lo que es
la regla de la cadena multi variable y
en este vídeo quiero explicar por qué es
cierta digamos con un poquito de
intuición así que la forma en la que
podemos pensar una expresión como esta
digamos tenemos esta función efe que
depende de dos variables digamos x y
verdad así que vamos a poner esto en
nuestro digamos en una especie de
espacio de entradas aquí tenemos el
plano x de verdad y como siempre
estaríamos pensando en una
transformación de este espacio digamos a
el espacio de salidas que es la recta en
este caso verdad aquí está nuestro
espacio de salidas y por otro lado
tenemos este otro espacio en donde vive
nuestra variable de verdad y estaríamos
pensando que cada punto de este espacio
verdad a través de otra transformación
la enviamos a este espacio intermedio
verdad que es el plano x de verdad
entonces tendremos que pensar a esta
función verdad que nos manda
digamos a este plano x tendríamos que
pensarlo como una función que tiene una
salida de dos dimensiones verdad una
entrada y dos salidas muy bien entonces
al pensarlo de esta forma resulta al
final en una función que toma una
variable de entrada verdad y hasta el
final tenemos una de salida así que el
único detalle es que tenemos un
intermediario multidimensional verdad
entonces si nosotros queremos pensar en
su derivada pensamos en este punto por
ejemplo de aquí y hacemos un pequeño
cambio un empujoncito en nuestra
variable t verdad entonces pensamos en
un pequeño empujoncito
dt por supuesto que esto va a provocar
otro empujoncito en nuestra salida
entonces por ejemplo si tenemos aquí
nuestro punto de salida luego hacer un
poquito más para acá verdad a lo mejor
esto nos dará otro empujón en este
espacio y lo estoy pintando digamos un
poco grande aunque tenemos que pensarlo
como un pequeño empujón
pero lo pinto grande para que se vea
claro y pueda yo dibujar y complementar
esta idea verdad ahora bien este empujón
que tenemos en en esta digamos en este
plano verdad provocará a la hora de
aplicar la siguiente transformación un
punto y un último empujoncito pero en el
espacio de salidas para efe verdad
entonces aquí tendremos un empujoncito
un d efe verdad y si nos ponemos a
pensar en este paso intermedio tenemos
está digamos este movimiento o esta este
pequeño cambio que también podemos
descomponerlo en sus componentes verdad
aquí esto nos provocará un pequeño
cambio en equis y un pequeño cambio en
verdad y en realidad no es no es un
cambio arbitrario en realidad es el
cambio que se genera debido a nuestro
pequeño cambio en dt verdad entonces en
realidad nosotros podríamos pensar
nuestro cambio en x verdad podríamos
pensar nuestro cambio en x que sea
proporcional
a nuestro cambio ente y si nos ponemos a
pensar en cuál sería ese factor que hace
este cambio en x debido al cambiante
pues eso tendría que ser digamos ese
factor tendría que ser la derivada de
nuestra función x dt verdad con respecto
a t verdad este es el factor que nos
dice a que corresponde un pequeño
empujoncito en la dirección x verdad y
de hecho por eso es que muchas personas
lo piensan como si fuera una como si
fueran fracciones y como si pudiéramos
cancelarlo verdad aunque bueno esto nada
más es una regla digamos esa es algo
nemotécnico es para que podamos recordar
cómo se comporta esto y por supuesto
también podríamos pensar esto mismo pero
en la dirección de verdad nuestro
pequeño cambio en que tendrá que ser
proporcional a nuestro cambio ente
verdad
y ese factor de proporcionalidad sería
la derivada de jake con respecto a t muy
bien eso es digamos el nuestro cambio en
la dirección y es por eso que es
bastante útil escribirlo como fracciones
verdad esto es en realidad
en the limits además de que digamos de
que es algo útil desde el punto de vista
técnico también refleja lo que se hace
cuando usamos un argumento más formal y
que seguro veremos en algún vídeo
posterior muy bien entonces finalmente
si nos preguntamos por el cambio final
en nuestra función
efe pues tendremos un cambio en x verdad
que se produce
tendremos tendremos más bien un cambio
en nuestra función
efe verdad pero que se produce por el
cambio en x bien y eso por supuesto
tendrá que ser proporcional a la
derivada parcial de nuestra función
efe con respecto a la variable x verdad
entonces este cambio que estoy anotando
aquí este cambio aquí es debido
nuestro cambio en x
debido a de x muy bien y por supuesto
nuevamente también tendremos un cambio
en nuestra función f debido al cambio y
entonces tendremos nuestro cambio en f
verdad será que digamos este será debido
a nuestro cambio en verdad esto será
proporcional al cambio en g
y el factor de proporcionalidad será la
derivada parcial de f con respecto a la
variable de verdad entonces si nosotros
juntamos estos dos digamos y juntamos
todo al al final hay dos cosas que están
provocando un cambio en f verdad así que
vamos a ver cómo se vería nuestro cambio
en f nuestro cambio ene efe sería por un
lado nuestro cambio debido al cambio en
x verdad entonces esto sería la derivada
parcial de f con respecto a x por de x
pero de x ya vimos que es proporcional
al cambio en dt y donde este este factor
es la derivada de x con respecto de t
entonces hay que multiplicar la derivada
de x con respecto a ate y luego
multiplicamos por dt y todo esto es
nuestro cambio debido al cambio en x
ahora debemos sumar también nuestro
cambio debido al cambio en verdad es
decir tendremos que sumar la derivada
parcial respecto de y por déja pero de
jay ya vimos que es la derivada de que
con respecto a t por nuestro cambiante
verdad entonces tendremos tendremos que
multiplicar esto por la derivada de jake
con respecto a t por de t muy bien
entonces este es digamos la forma en la
que podemos ver el cambio de nuestra
función verdad entonces nosotros lo que
podríamos hacer es dividir todo esto
entre de verdad podríamos dividir todo
esto entre dt y si dividimos de este
lado tenemos que dividir también de este
otro lado entre dt así que
a quitar todo esto quitemos todo esto
pongamos aquí el signo más digamos en
medio vamos a ponerlo aquí y entonces
aquí hemos obtenido nuevamente la
fórmula que bueno digamos con lo que
habíamos iniciado el vídeo pero esta es
la fórmula de la regla de la cadena
multivariable verdad entonces justamente
en estas partes se ven como podrían
incluso también cancelar se de equis y
de verdad para expresar nuestro cambio
en nuestra función f verdad pero bueno
espero que esto te haya ayudado a tener
una mejor intuición de la regla de la
cadena y de cómo pensamos en pequeños
cambios consecutivos verdad a medida que
vamos componiendo nuestra función creo
que esto da una muy buena idea de por
qué la regla de la cadena es cierta